so then the thing which i should have
been able to figure out but didn't
is
in assume that there's a simple
underlying rule for the universe that's
computational irreducibility that
produces immense complexity in the
behavior of the universe how come we can
figure out anything about the universe
how come we can even say the universe
follows definite laws how come we can
predict what's going to happen at all
why isn't it just a whole mass of
irreducibility and what you realize is
within any computational irreducible
system there are always these pockets of
reducibility there are always pockets
yeah there are always pockets of
reduceability it's it's uh so there is
no way to construct a system that's
computationally irreducible that has no
pockets of reduceability i believe that
to be correct okay but i i mean there no
i mean that's a
to
fully formalize that notion would be
quite interesting i suspect that you can
get some formalization through speed up
theorems in in computation theory but um
uh i think it's
it is intuitively fairly obvious but if
as you try and nail it down um uh there
will be you know i think the speed up
theorems are the way to think about that
in a somewhat more formal way but um so
in any case the the um uh the thing that
one realizes is
so there are these pockets of
reduceability that exist
and the thing that is sort of the the
big surprise is
those pockets correspond to the big
theories of physics
each one has probed some pocket now the
next question is
are there other pockets
that have never been discovered that are
theories of physics that we just don't
know that are complete global theories
like general relativity like quantum
mechanics but we don't know them and
what i realized recently is
that
the
the kind of the the
you know
the reason that we know those theories
is because there are certain attributes
that we as observers of the universe
have
and those attributes lead us to those
theories so the attributes are things
like that we have a computationally
bounded way of understanding the
universe
now that's one of them another one is
that we have a definite
thread of experience in time
we
we are we are not
operating with many many many threads of
experience we have a definite sort of
thread of consciousness that we follow
we're not um uh
and that and in fact the thing i
realized just in the last week actually
um is
one of the things that is non-trivial in
our models is the notion of uh
maintaining your identity so to speak so
in this hypograph
every
every atom of space is being destroyed a
new one is being created all the time
so the question is how come you and me
seem like we sort of exist through time
turns out our atoms of space are being
destroyed and recreated you know
whatever it is ten to the hundred times
per second so in other words how come we
are a thing we maintain our identity
that is a non-trivial fact about us as
observers that we
we
we consider ourselves to maintain our
identity
and through time the thing i realized
just recently is there's a similar way
in which we do that in space
it is not obvious that there would be a
pure notion of motion
that is that you could move you know as
i move from here to there
the atoms of space that are in me are
different
and right yet me i have an identity that
i think i can carry around i can carry
it through time i carry it around in
space the assumption
that i maintain that identity
is what ends up being sort of a tale
that wags eventually that gives us the
laws of physics that we know in other
words if we did not have that assumption
about ourselves
we would have different laws of physics
and if we didn't have
for example the the notion that
oh i don't know there's quantum
measurements occur the notion that we we
collapse all these different paths of
history into a single definite outcome
that is directly related to the fact
that we imagine that we maintain a
definite identity through time
that in other words if if we just said
oh i don't care about that i'm not going
to maintain a definite identity through
time i'm perfectly happy to have myself
branched a zillion times
then you no longer get this idea that we
imagine about quantum mechanics that
there are somewhat there are definite
outcomes that occur so in other words
it's it's our
our
way of constructing ourselves and the
way we think about ourselves
and the way we kind of perceive the
universe that drives the structure of
the laws of physics that that we know
so one of the things that that obviously
leads to is well maybe there are
completely other laws of physics and a
completely other sort of plane of
existence that we are utterly unfamiliar
with